when I'm out in LA on time - nonsense I
got a report that John Hein and Gary and
it annoys the [ __ ] they somehow have
time to go to the Brady Bunch house I
saw John Hines photos from The Brady
Bunch house yeah and it's like that's
going too far
yeah it disgusted me like they don't
know how that disgusts me
and there's all these pictures of John
and Gary in like the Brady's bedroom
right there shoes beds at the bunker and
and John had to take his shoes off and
he wasn't wearing socks and he's in his
bare feet and then Gary went back and
had to get his picture taken solo
without John in it you know what I think
I think that those who are trying to
one-up each other on the douchiness yeah
I mean it's like like what like you
shouldn't have that much time in your
life when you work on a show like this
just you know what Gary's entitled to
his free time and yes I have downtime
and I paint stuff but it just annoys me
when Gary has free time and what he does
with it it does what he's listening to
fine I don't know it just dies you could
go to a great museum Gary well I go to
the Brady house Gary they were going and
eyeing in every room they went to like
literally going [ __ ] waste of time
when he could have been meeting with my
guys and being part of the writing
process it just annoys me I'm sorry Gary
you do you annoy the [ __ ] out just so
much dumb [ __ ] Harry here's a fact
that'll really make you nuts Gary and
John asked the tour guide what were the
quote best angles to take pictures of
themselves so it looked like so it would
look like it did on TV yeah excuse me
excuse me
I wonder who asked that [ __ ] quick
excuse me that was John I bet I say it
to Gary
I met Gary I say Gary
all right you're on who did it the guy
who was showing us the house told us
what he thought was the best angle you
didn't ask
ask is it true you guys chose the order
of the rooms that you saw you chose the
Attic last you wanted to why would you
do this I was kind of following what
John wanted to see the Attic last why
hey why don't you guys just [ __ ] each
other seems like you're having sexual
attention the guy the tour guy said look
we can do this in any order you want a
lot of people particularly you know so I
was like let's go to the attic glass cuz
it's the last room you see if you're
doing like a regular tour of a house do
you guys understand my annoyance with
this at all or is it like just baffling
to you that I'm really when I saw the
pictures I genuinely wanted to throw up
a little bit I sort of understand it
because to you it seems like you know a
horror show for me and for Gary it was a
fun thing to do on you know anyway you
said it was the best thing you did in LA
did say that I loved the fact that I got
to do that it was a unique opportunity
I'm born and raised on TV as you guys
know yeah I thought it was a cool thing
to do
you weren't skeeved out being on their
carpet where thousands of people walk
around and you're in your bare feet I
didn't know we had to take our shoes off
or I would have worn socks but at that
point it was too late
right behind I don't know it annoyed the
piss out of me when I saw the pictures I
was just like these two [ __ ] guys
have too much free time you should not
be doing that with your free time but
sure would you like going to a weed cafe
like some of the others no no I don't
suggest that but you should let like
learn something great learn to play
chess or learn to paint for example
Robin said we should go to a museum
Robin this is my museum